what of your donkey and your dog were
giant animals what would you do I need I
need more land and a lot more dog food
and donkey for a job yeah a big animal
lover yes do you remember the first time
you got a pet I've always had a dog I I
mean I I always remember at least having
a dog in my life yeah yeah it's for me I
mean other than my kid kids now I got to
yeah yeah yeah yeah I just forgot I'm
like oh crap there's two of them yeah
I'm like delirious no I you know we
brought we brought everybody out from
New York and I'm just like it's a lot
it's a lot yo yeah she's here Shane Gus
my little son but I think they just went
inside I think Gus was like I gotta go
the bathroom so let's get out of it yeah
yeah you made the movie a year ago and
you're back with your crew and cast that
must be exciting for it's really
exciting I mean we do we I was working
on it a year ago right now it's amazing
how fast they could turn around a movie
like this was so much kind of special
effects but yeah it seems like we just
finished filming and we did we did some
reshoots as a matter of fact like in
december so god that wasn't that long
ago yeah yeah
jeonse I mean everyone's asking about
Dwayne Johnson I mean I think we're just
all in love with him it's hard not to be
in love
Manny smells awesome yeah like really
like I don't know what his Cologne is
cuz I but I want to ask him cuz it's
that delicious yeah yeah when he comes
over you know taking a little whip
because I mean I remember working with
I'm in like like doing stunts and stuff
and he's I claimed on me I'd be like how
do you smell delicious can you please
get off me before you break every bone
in my body right yeah
congratulation can't wait to see the
film thank you very much thank you